then can't be here just now hopefully
you'll be here shortly had a stilt
mishap that does happen now I'm going to
kick things off with a question for
everyone a classic first base one but
let's just do it I'd love to know how
you guys all individually got involved
with the project and what appealed to
you the roles in particular because all
quite different I'd say maybe kick
things off with count do you mind oh um
well I just got a call from my agent and
they were like are you willing to shave
your head for a role in a Marvel film
and I said absolutely
um and then I just auditioned and then
if you know this is a boring story I'm
gonna make this interesting and then I
met James in the studio Shepherdson
where we shot the film and it was really
exciting and then I did a screen test
and got the role it was really appealing
B times X and I told her the other day
in person Karen's auditions my fate or
her screen test is my fate sorry guys
but her screen test is my favorite
audition of anybody in the entire
process was you know her her audition
was my favorite it's the coolest I gotta
ask why because she was so good it was
like if she took this character that was
a pretty simple character and it was you
know a little bit it was a pretty long
sequence and it was just very it was
actually very moving this character that
she created out of this bald cyber jerk
so I like this yeah yeah and I think
that it's in you know her character is
sort of we think of her she's almost
like the boba fett of the movie and she
has some just these little moments in
the movie where you can see that there's
a lot more to this character than just
being a villainous Boba Fett big shoes
to fill chill uh Chris can he be count
story how was your screen test did you
know from the off that you were ready
for this um I I figured if I could just
get them to believe me physically as the
character that I would be mine I really
felt like James and I'm gelled in a nice
way and seemed to have the like almost
immediately I felt like I was right like
my spirit was right for this character
and the way I sounded was the way he'd
sound I just didn't look the
I didn't look the part and I wasn't
walking around in like the the right
vehicle yet and so I knew if I could
convince them that they could take a
chance on me and give me a given enough
time I'd be able to make a physical like
create the you know change that was
required to look like the character I
knew I would get the part and so so and
I also had an insight in because my
friend Ben who was essentially reading
the role of Drax for all of the other
screen tests is like one of my very best
friends and he's also one of my best
friend yeah and we were really and he
was like he's like dude you can't Pratt
you can't tell anyone but it's totally
yours like no one has come in and did
what you did you're gonna get it I was
like oh that's good well I told I told
Ben I was like oh I won't I'm just I am
just now just like trying to check if
the boxes to get Pratt into the role so
that he can he can be hired by Marvel
and they can agree to tire him with Dave
it was a David was the same thing I knew
you know the interesting thing with me
with all four of these actors here is
you know I think back along the journey
and with each one of them like the
minute we met there was something very
like just sincere between each of us the
first time I met you know Dave in that
audition room I just really got Dave
Chris and I had common friends and we
met each other you know Karen remember
you know hanging out in my office and
just laughing our asses off and that
that first day we met and then Zoey on
the phone who's a good thousand miles a
minute a lot when I was on the phone
with you and just totally just got along
really well so it's one of those cool
things where you still love everybody at
the end of the project that you you know
like so much at the beginning and that's
probably coolest thing about this movie
for me it sounds like you had a great
wrap party with that kind of chemistry
between you guys you know we broke okay
barking whoops I missed the rap yeah I
always miss rap parties like I always
have to leave the day of the wrap party
and then I hear the stories but it's a
good thing that I don't go to the wrap
party cuz I tend to wrap the party too
yeah David date no David me cause you've
got Newport ass you protected my brother
from a guy that was trying to beat him
up Dave
dave has there's a guy haha like that oh
there's a guy who there's a guy who was
like a crew member who was bothering a
bunch of people and he came up and he
was like offering me drugs and I don't
even drink in it like what do you you
know get away from me and then he was
you know he like you know grabbed the
little person who played who was like
the reference for rocket on set he
grabbed her he rrt and then he there was
another girl Abby who was one of the
stand-ins and he grabbed her butt and my
brother Sean who plays cry Glenn in the
movie who was on the onset rock rocket
who's not a big guy you know got in this
guy's face and he was a big guy and he's
like you know what what are you doing
and I and somebody ran over to me and
said your brother's about to get into a
fight and I walked over to the guy and
I'm like you know you got to get out of
here you know leave cuz he grabbed you
know this this girl and then Artie who
was the stand and came up and said James
he picked me up by the tips and I said
whoa and dave was there and Dave said
what's the problem and then this big guy
came marching over to Dave and he's like
about to get in Dave's face and dave has
actual superpower so it's pretty cool
and Dave just went like this with his
hand he went yeah and he went he he
tapped the guy like like this and then
the guy flew back like 30 feet it was
awesome with actual superpowers that
they passed that was great I was pretty
excited way times when you also want how
the rap
was that is not the answer you expect I
think it's time sin of some questions
from you guys if you'd like well there
you have it hands up already
let's go for the gentlemen here with his
hand up if that's possible
I say gentlemen it's a rather younger
gentleman this is it this is setup guys
I'm sorry you all play incredible roles
but in your opinion who do you think
stole the show the most in the movie
fight fight fight fight stole the show
in the movie in your opinion who stole
the show when we watched him for me I
would have to say you know uh Groot they
just I mean he stole the show when we
started working I just had a soft spot
for that big tree he was so he
unconditionally loved us all and and
even though you know I'm mature and I'm
pretty sane and I'm I'm an actor
um uh you know and you go okay this is
make-believe I know it's a fictional
character he moved me in such a way that
I was I screw that like I just I want to
believe that he's real because what he's
making me feel is very real such group
we have one for group I think well I
think for me I mean you know when the
movie for me when the movie really takes
off is the is when we we zoom in on this
and our mall and we meet rocket and
group together when you see Groot
drinking out of the fountain and you see
rocket with you know looking through his
vid screen for potential bounties and
that to me is the moment that like
there's this synergy that happens like
you take all of the parts the Peter
quill you've met Gamora we you know I
don't think at that point we met Drax
yet but you see like somehow the sum is
greater than the whole and and it's when
rocket is talking and he sees like a
little kid and he's like who's this
little guy like look at this little you
know it's not cool to need helper you
know and it's like it becomes really fun
and you just you see that this world you
know this journey is gonna be really
good so I'd say rocket I think rocket
probably in that moment steals the show
from me
I suppose James for you is like picking
your flavor
Cave isn't it well I have my favorite
kid it's rocket but I don't know if you
can say steals the show it's a for me in
some ways I think you know GRU I just go
by the tweets I get and it's you know
and frankly I get more tweets about
Groot and Batista than anybody else I
also like I like to say it's Batista
that steals the show because it
embarrasses him and so and so he's the
one person I like the compliment as much
as possible because he hates it but
really you know I think everybody steals
it you know Chris obviously has emerged
as a giant movie star from this movie
which is incredible and Zooey is kind of
the Clint Eastwood and pretty movie star
you know yeah you are already a movie
star and Karen is just so visually
arresting I think of her as like just as
just as Jesus gigantic like beauty and
charisma that's just so present Rockets
you know maybe the funniest and Groot is
the soul of the movie and then you know
Batista comes in and he's just the most
unique character in the whole movie and
he's so funny and there's nobody else in
the world that could play that role so
it's you know and actually one of the
comments I got the most like on Twitter
and Facebook from people who've seen the
movie is that everybody kind of steals
the movie in turn and it really is and
then samba piece and I think that's what
makes it so good there isn't that one
character who everybody says oh it's
this one guy it's really the dynamism
between the characters together that
works more so than any individual
character oh it's the prosthetic leg
which which is means the director yeah
sure
another question how about this
gentleman right the phone
Zoe Kermit the Frog once famously saying
that it's not easy being green how did
you find it let me tell you something
when you think of things that are sexy
they're usually in pink or black or
white or red they're not in green we
don't even like vegetables half of us
don't even eat veg we started out with a
really tough in a very tough position
and I and I I've never approached a
character on a superficial level in
terms of like get me tickets bigger and
and make the jeans tighter around the
bud and this time you should have been
in the in the wardrobe room when I was
having a fitting I was like no Alex but
get to pad them up more you just make
them like they're like out here and the
ass get that wedgie just perfect I was
really concerned because I thought if my
character has to bring all the fanboys
and find it appealing we like things
that are aesthetically beautiful
especially if it comes in a form of a
woman and you know green or Martians
Swamp things are green boogers are green
it's like you know this isn't so we I
was adamant about finding that right
shade
of devil could ask you you know being
gray what's it like but the tribal
tattoos fascinate me how hard is it to
get that on every morning oh so I'm
still stuffing boogers are green yeah
yeah no it was okay it was um it wasn't
nearly as bad as people think for some
reason because I'd really become close
with my makeup team mm-hmm and now so
the comparison I like to make is if you
could you know imagine yourself just
hanging out with five your friends for
four hours and havin some good
conversation a lot of laughs and
listening to good music it it kind of
flies by yeah you know but if it was
more the consecutive days rather than
the hours in the chair it was like when
it got to be like three four five six
days in a row then your skin just got
real since
kind of wrong you just want that day off
to feel clean you don't take a shower
and stop digging gunk out of your ears
and blowing stuff out of your nose you
pull green out of your nose but ya know
it wasn't as bad as you would think it's
good you just mostly cuz you have a good
attitude like it didn't ya and I know
many patients yeah yeah cuz he's really
he was for like he'd have to have his
arms outstretched like this for long
periods of time and it's to me it would
be absolute hell because I have to be
moving all the time it would be very
difficult but I think one of the with
with the green the interesting thing for
me is like if I had to go back I would
really consider you know even though
she's green in the comic books changing
her colors it was so hard it took us so
long to find a green that works guys
wouldn't believe because we found you
know right away you know we have other
characters who are blue you know yondu
and ronan are both blue and nebulas blue
we have other characters who are you
know smaller characters who are yellow
we have other characters who are pink
and we found all of those colors were
sort of you know natural to human beings
in a strange sort of way you could find
a color that looked like skin and green
was really hard and it just took a long
time it really was a struggle yeah like
I remember some of the some like being
in the makeup room and seeing some of
the tests and it was like a lighter
shade of green and then she just looked
like she was seasick yeah it was like
darker shade of green it was like Matt
looks like someone got painted green yes
exactly that's what good at all they
look painted yeah is like green is not a
natural color that looks good on the
skin so it was really you know hard it's
a you know and the testament is always
facial features to that it ends up
looking as good as it does I
I'm guessing County you had the longest
in the makeup did I did yeah
five hours I didn't stand up and put my
arms out though I just watched Pulp
Fiction on repeat it was really fun
Wow for every elf
next question is going to be from
somebody over in that direction and it's
going to be that man next to the camera
there with a check shirt that's you
yeah with a just behind you if the if
the Guardians were to one day meet the
Avengers who would you like to work with
or perhaps collide with I would like to
see them kill Thor I don't know this is
true Chris Chris and I were driving the
other day where are we going
Thor's like the only one that came to
the premiered yeah there was never
support I'm kidding about the warhead
let's kill Thor he's walking but but
Chris and I were driving somewhere the
other day and we were in the car and we
were one in one of our ridiculous
conversations and we're talking about
all the different things that could
happen to the guardians in this universe
as we do endlessly you know you think
we're sick of hearing about the
Guardians no we talk about it constantly
and Eddie and he was saying dude
seriously it I really really think that
star-lord should kill Iron Man like the
audience would be it would be so awesome
if he came down and he shot Tony Stark
in the face
people would be so surprised
stuff like yeah they would thank you you
know I know you do I know
more like worry not me maybe rocket yeah
rocket I don't know I think I some into
his heart like that shiny I guess you
know the without giving away any you
know look none of my ideas will ever
make the movie so I should just tell you
all of them cuz it wouldn't it will
never be a spoiler but I know that like
in the comic like Gamora and iron and
Iron Man you know they have in through
the comics that they've hooked up and
how does Peter quill feel about that
maybe he doesn't like it and then maybe
rocket hears it that I don't like it and
then rocket shoots Tony Stark
minute five just blows a hole in his
face that would be amazing people would
be super mad but it would be kind of
great that you'd be like what how did
you do that in there like cuz Robert
Downey jr. makes a hundred million
dollars movie we can't afford to have
yeah
crash minimum wage let's keep him around
yeah yeah we could afford Pratt he kills
everyone
I would pay good money to read the
fanfiction you write yeah I think that
answers your question um next how about
this gentleman with the black cat here
with his phone in his head
yeah my question mostly goes to Chris
and James but a b.a.p that you all
answer it um what songs do you get do
you guys want in the awesome mixtape vol
2
um well I haven't you know I haven't
figured out quite awesome mix vol 2 yet
so they're really you know the truth is
the songs that were chosen for the movie
were chosen to be specific to those
scenes so it isn't so much about what
you know what songs I like the best as
it is about what songs speak to that
scene and all those songs were written
into the script except for one and so
they were you know all part they're sort
of baked into the story of the guardians
of the galaxy which is what makes it
work so
well so for me to think of a song that I
like a lot that I want to put in the
movie it doesn't necessarily mean it
works I mean one of my favorite scenes
in the movie was two yellows a living
thing which we cut from the film and
that was to me living thing was like the
main guardian song because it was so
yellow seemed like the guardians house
band almost and now there's no elo song
in there but it still it works really
well because the movie works better
without that scene we need some Abba in
it we need some challah notes and some
air supply I had used air supply in
slither so I paid my undersupply
fabulous I wouldn't I wouldn't mind
seeing Peter quill try to seduce
somebody to like Lionel Richie
yeah like put it on like he's a Mac
hello me on looking phone and they're
just like like super serious and play a
real like that's how he's been getting
with all these millions is just like
this one Milo G purple girl some purple
groans she's just like crying cuz it's
so beautiful the most beautiful thing
she's ever heard just super easy to hook
up with a few millions it's all you need
is Lionel Richie this is this is what we
do guys mammalian it is really a fact
that the millions loved Lionel Richie
yeah everyone knows yeah I just really
want to ask what song will be playing
when you care line man I mean probably
not Lionel Richie oh no me oh look into
shock credits roll seven minutes into
the movie it's over only worth it and
then the rest of the movie is like a
weekend at Bernie's yeah we've got a
Betty fingers body to keep to making the
most out of his conscious skittering
across the desert with the Iron Man
thrusters on is this [ __ ] is that body
in the Iron Man cast yeah totally
somebody get up a basket ask a question
it's enough it's gonna we're gonna keep
going although I gosh I'm taking control
the situation is what it was like one
more question a let's have a relatively
serious one if that's possible um
who this lady here hi first off thank
you for having a raccoon in the film and
because you've got the recruit in the
film Oreo is now coming to my wedding so
thank you oh great
yes Oreo raccoon is the he's the rescue
raccoon he was rescued when he was only
I think four days old and hand fed and
he's the raccoon who came with me is my
date to the premiere last night and he
was the reference raccoon for rocket and
he's a real sweet little guy and I
actually after the premiere I went over
there and he tackled me and didn't rip
my suit but that's alright
yeah you be careful he's very he's very
nice he'll never try to hurt you but he
likes to wrestle yeah but my question is
it's for everybody but Chris your
character che in the OSI and had an
otter as a spirit animal I was just
wondering what each guardians it's very
tiny what would be Wow
what what she's talking about some of
she's talking about this like a really
profound season of The OC where my
character my character che Winchester
had a spirit animal which was an otter
and it's really deep it's like really
kind of a subversive I mean actually if
you have like 45 minutes I could kind of
walk you through the episode um no yeah
but that's a really good question I if
everyone what's your spirit animal
what's your character's spirit animal
would be the question I don't know do
you guys have an answer I'd like to
point out I asked for a serious question
but um you know I guess for me my spirit
Peter Quill's spirit animal would
probably be like golden retriever
yeah yeah I see that guys doing that
yeah he's a putt he goes he's a puppy
he's like a puppy you know we're you
know he's still kind of that nine year
old boy that got taken away buddy but
he's like ah screw it I'm gonna chase my
tail and chase frisbees you know anyone
else I think um usually I always find an
animal for all the characters that I
play I just feel like people we do also
have animal personalities and and and
that's a good way of getting to know
somebody on a primal level but this time
Gamora wasn't an animal you may think
it's a reptile but it wasn't um she was
more of a bull fighter for me because
obviously a woman cannot out out fight a
man with her strength but she can outwit
him so I thought both fighters
definitely seducible into surrendering
into the sword which obviously is not is
not something that I appreciate deeply
but the psychological journey of that
moment is is something worth just like
just observing and noticing so I just
thought well if she's a woman she's not
going to be stronger than a lot of of
her opponents but she's definitely to be
whittier so yeah how about you Dave
what's what's your spirit animal my
spirit animal yeah for Drax yes I both
know it probably something like a big
dumb dog like great thing or something
oh yeah yeah we're gonna go for another
dog here Karen are you gonna take I mean
what animal takes itself way too
seriously maybe like a sloth no that's
those are passive um maybe I don't know
what's a really serious animal like a
tiger like a short shark that one a
cybernetic shark all right this lady
here with a gray top on and glasses I
know um Chris those are some
impressively smooth dance moves you do
devastating dance moves and did you come
up with the choreography yourself
um you yes yes I did
that was sort of a you know kind of a
throwback I think like I like everything
about Peter quill it had to be 1988 or
earlier and so I thought of a lot of
Michael Jackson some moves from the
disco era a little bit of early hip hop
and and stuff like that so I remember
around that time in my life my brother
and I would have dance offs in our in
our basement and so uh there was sort of
that spirit in it a little bit but yeah
those are those are my moves and oddly
never got paid as a choreographer um
he's not yet so what got to thank young
for a couple more gentlemen here James
they say that movies are made three
times in scripts when it's shot and in
editing and wandering with a presence
like this this film where there wasn't a
huge notoriety for the characters in
advance whether you had slightly more
freedom to shape it in a way personally
rather than necessarily the way a studio
would do for a really well-known
characters did I get the chance to do
that as I was walking but it wasn't
because it's because you're introducing
the characters rather than reflecting
existing characters yeah I mean now for
me there was a whole appeal of this
project in the first place was to create
not just a world but many worlds and I
think I would have a very hard time
doing like a sequel to another Marvel
movie or even setting up another
character to be in the Avengers but I
felt a lot of freedom in creating this
movie and I'm very very grateful to
Marvel because every time I came up with
some crazy idea I'm like you know let's
just have a seven-page scene where the
characters argue about stupid stuff at
the beginning of the third act and
Marvel is like oh that's great we love
it or you know let's you know just have
all these bright colors like old 50s and
60s movies they're like we love it and
I'm like what's that Michael Rooker
who's totally insane and put him in the
role a yondu and they're like we love it
and it's just like they really for some
reason you know I was allowed to go
hog-wild and it's been an amazing
experience and I know
all of us unless they're you know being
dishonest with me which I don't believe
they are this has felt like a special
movie to all of us from the very
beginning and it just was sort of the
flavor of it the flavor of it was was
special and we felt like we were doing
something that was both very new very
unique and then also hearken back to the
films that we all loved as a kid I mean
one of my favorite moments is showing
Zoey some scenes during the dubbing
scene she's like jumping around like a
little kid because it was like I
remember how I felt when I saw Raiders
of the Lost Ark when I was a little kid
or Empire Strikes Back and her
Spaceballs so it was fun to to create
you know to create that sort of thing
and try to make something that's you
know so many movies today are so dark
and brooding to be able to create
something that's a little bit you know
more fun but yet also has the emotional
weight and the you know the heart to it
as well one last question and I feel
obliged to pick the guy with an Iron Man
t-shirt thanks guys uh thanks great to
have you here I love the film a couple
questions firstly for James I think this
is one of the best marketing campaigns
for Marvel film that I've seen and I
recognize that some of the footage we
saw in the trailers wasn't in the final
film so how much British can we expect
to see in deleted scenes and then for
the cast was any particular scene that
you filmed which didn't make the cut
that you would have liked to have made
the cut there's a there's a few deleted
scenes that we have that aren't in the
movie and there are also outtakes of
things that because we would goof around
a lot on set doing things and sometimes
those are using the trailer as well and
so the I forgot your quest which deleted
Satan's do you wish she could have well
no there's another question before that
marketing oh the marketing the marketing
is amazing
like the truth is I'll be completely
honest with you like we went out and we
tested those original trailers that we
did for the movie we had like a really
like mainstream one that made it look
all serious and that these guys
guys were like you know made it look
like a very just normal like science
fiction space movie and then we had the
trailer that we did with hooked on a
feeling and all of that stuff and we
took him out to malls and showed people
and people were kind of like I don't
like any of these you know um him so
we're like well if they hate them all
then we might as well go with the one
that is most honest and true to the film
which was hooked on a feeling one which
really gave you a flavor of what the
movie was and it just shows you that
stuff is all [ __ ] because people
then love the trailer we beat every
other movie and you know we had you know
in the time slot we had three times the
amount of hits that Man of Steel had on
the first day and nobody knows who the
guardians of the galaxy are so it worked
really well and it was just because it
was true to the movie and that's been
our philosophy every step of the way and
and this is really a testament to you
know I've given tribute them to Marvel
but it's Disney the Disney marketing
team who decided to have the balls to
just kind of sell this movie as what it
is and not try to make it into something
else that's more palatable to what they
think of is middle America and and that
has been a pretty cool experience and
and marketing you know the test would
have said don't do that and they did it
and somehow we'll find out if in a
couple days but it it seems to have
worked pretty well
scenes there's there's a there is there
a couple of scenes that we shot Gamora
and nebula where you sort of explain
that dysfunctional relationship that
Ronan and nebula and Gomorrah had by
being abducted and forced into a life of
crime and violence by Thanos and his
group of thugs and um and I would love
to to see that in the DVD me too yeah me
too thank you all for coming to this
rather uproarious press conference I'm
sure Vin Diesel it's about to spring in
any moment but this this this has been
the guardians galaxy press conference in
London thank you so much everybody for
coming down
thanks guys
you